millions of Americans use home genetic
tests like ancestry DNA or 23andme to
explore their roots and connect with
distant relatives john gonzalvez
took a DNA test last year to learn about
his European ancestors but his results
told him a lot more and led to a meeting
40 years in the making
Elaine Quijano of our streaming network
cbsn has the story you'll see only on
CBS this morning Elaine good morning
good morning John Gonzalez got the
surprise of his life when he got an
ancestry DNA kit for his birthday from
his daughter Robin he discovered he had
another daughter from a relationship
prior to Robins mother the discovery led
to a surprise meeting and we were there
to witness the joy John Gonzalez is an
hour away from meeting his daughter for
the first time you have to forgive me
it's not every day did she become a
father at 59 the twist she's 40 years
old just as exciting to me to have a
daughter who was 40 years old is one
that's only one month old and he just
found out about her in June she must be
approaching his other daughter Robin is
with him I'm just nervous excited and
I'm curious to see what she's like Jini
Siciliano was born in 1977 the product
of John's highschool relationship and
was adopted two months later when she
was 19 she looked for her biological
parents she found her birth mother but
not her father I did some searching but
I didn't come up with any solid
information so I kind of put that all to
the side so then I fast forward to this
year you decided to submit a DNA test
why did you want to do that my birth
mother is Italian and Irish and she's
very fair and so I was curious where my
you know physicality came from and so I
wanted to know what my heritage was when
I first opened my ancestry DNA calm
results and John's name came up and
underneath it it said father and I was
like holy cannoli
this guy's a biological father oh my
gosh
soon after she wrote him a letter good
morning John how are you
so it seems we have pretty similar DNA
lol you are listed as my biological
father and Robin is listed as my close
relative I was stunned I literally felt
the world stopped and the second thought
was there's a scam there's no way that I
could have a child forty years old and
then I started to cry I started graduate
I felt joy I I was like this is such a
great gift two months later the big
moment arrived I'm about to meet my
biological father from the first time
I'm pretty anxious yes
[Music]
a father finally with both of his
daughters I get a shot with my daughters
it's in a way Robin was responsible for
this moment she gave her dad the DNA kit
as a birthday gift I knew that he wanted
and I never know what to get him and he
had been talking about it so I gave him
the gift of another child how do you see
a relationship with Robin developing
here when I found out that Robin's mom
passed away a few years ago my heart
kind of broke for her Here I am 20 years
older than her you know nobody can
obviously replace your mother but like
maybe I can be there for her I'm also
like super immature she'll probably make
better more mature decisions than I will
I'll be calling her like dude there's
this guy and I don't know what do you
think about that yeah I mean that's
great I love guy advice I think when I
lost my mom the thing that I was most
concerned about was like how am I gonna
navigate my dating life like with my mom
I don't have too many women figures in
my life but my mom was really hard so
it's important to have women to look up
to you and so having someone like genius
really nice it does feel like a blessing
now that you have had the opportunity to
talk and to meet each other what has it
been like just knowing her for this
brief period of time it's cool I feel
like really cool
I'm entering the fourth quarter of life
and God has given me that opportunity
and
and it's gonna be an awesome fourth
quarter and we're going to win and
despite some of the challenges that
still exist out there that will conquer
them John and Jeannie lived only three
miles apart for 11 years of their lives
and even shopped at the same grocery
store they think they must have crossed
paths countless times but believe it was
divine intervention that brought them
all together now at a time when they
needed it most
holy cannoli she's terrific
he's awesome I feel the reality show
script has already been you know there
are two seasons booked yeah well you
know it's interesting I asked also about
her adoptive parents how did they take
the news and she said that her dad a
former Marine cried tears of joy
happiness that this all came to such a
happy conclusion cracklin story I love
that Dad I love it
great story Elaine thank you